well let's turn to labor now shall we
and find out what they made of that
interview with the chancellor we can
speak now to the shadow Chancellor
Rachel Reeves who joins us now from
Leeds thank you very much for being on
the program at this morning
um Jeremy Hunt telling me there that
everyone is going to be paying a little
bit more tax after next week do you
think he's got the right plan
well we'll see what he comes up with on
Thursday but I am determined to hold him
to account for having a fair tax system
and what I would like to see on Thursday
and what I would be doing if I was
Chancellor of the exchequer is closing
some of the tax loopholes which mean
today that some of the wealthiest in
society and some of the most biggest
businesses are not paying their fair
share of taxes that's why for example
when the when the Prime Minister flies
off to the G20 Summit today he should be
committing to closing some of those
loopholes that mean big Global
multinationals not paying their fair
share of tax there is already a global
agreement but we haven't legislated for
it here in the UK and it could bring in
7 billion pounds a year as well as
helping some of our smaller businesses
and High Street businesses as you know
Sophie I've been banging on about the
windfall tax on big energy companies
since the beginning of this year and the
Prime Minister when he was Chancellor
slow pedaled on that we still think that
you could raise an additional 50 billion
pounds through extending the windfall
tax by about two years by back dating it
to the beginning of January when those
windfalls those profits of War started
coming onto the balance sheets of the
energy companies by getting rid of some
of the loopholes that mean companies
like shell are not even paying any of
the government's energy profits Levy and
extending it to some of the electricity
generators so there are fair choices
that the chancellor could be making this
week rather than just putting all of
that burden on ordinary working people
who are already struggling with the
highest inflation that any of us have
experienced for 40 years and now risk
more of their money going in taxes
rather than having it for the weekly
food shop the higher mortgage payments
and everything else that is facing
people right now and I take your point
that labor was of course the first to
call for the windfall tax on energy
firms but it does look like according to
reports that the government is going to
be extending uh that uh next week Jeremy
Hunt was also talking about the cops let
me just say let me just
let me just say it on a win four tax I
hope the government does extend it but I
hope they do what labor are calling for
which is ensuring that the tax paid by
energy companies here is similar to what
it is in Norway and that we get rid of
those loopholes that mean for more
investment in fossil fuels those energy
companies can offset the wind forecast
that is not right companies should be
paying their fair share and that would
ease the pressure on the tax burden for
ordinary working people okay the
question that I was going to ask was
that Jeremy Hunt was also talking about
the cost of the energy support package
saying that with the rise in energy
bills it's going to be like funding a
second NHS so I just wonder what Labor's
plan is how long do you think the energy
price guarantee should last and is there
a point when actually it should be
targeted at the most vulnerable
pensioners those on low incomes rather
than just everybody
well when um Kia Stormer and me set out
our plans for the Autumn um winter
months and we did that in August at that
time the conservatives were all saying
um that they didn't believe in in
handouts they're constantly playing
catch up with what labor are putting
forward and of course the new Chancellor
Jeremy Hunt would reduce the support
that was available to people now look
we'll see where we are going into the
new year and where energy uh prices are
but labor have always been very clear
that the windfall tax on energy
companies should be used to try and keep
bills as low as possible for pensioners
for families and also for businesses and
you know I speak to many businesses
including here in Leeds and in fact I
was talking to one business owner
yesterday who said that she wasn't even
able to get a contract for energy so she
doesn't know from one week to the next
what she's paying because she's now just
on a floating a deal tracking Energy
prices that's incredibly difficult for
her and her business because energy
costs are a big part of it so we need
more certainty and Clarity from the
government you're not giving us what is
going to be available after after April
you're not giving the certainty in
Clarity either though are you because I
just asked you know firstly if you think
it should be targeted and secondly how
long it would last for under labor
well I I've made this commitment that we
would extend the uh windfall tax on
those big oil and gas companies and
we've always said that if you do that
there's more money to help people with
their gas and electricity uh bills and
the government have always slow pedaled
on the support that is needed it's why
also labor came up with a package for
some of our most energy intensive
Industries who are being put a
comparative disadvantage compared with
some of our International competitors
who are being supported and the
government has never come up with a
package to help them in September you
said on GMB austerity is not the right
approach we will oppose any cuts to
Public Services is that still your
position that you will oppose any cuts
to Public Services
public services are already on their
knees seven million people are waiting
for an NHS operation uh or or support
um you know if you look at our schools
our class sizes are increasing teachers
are increasingly having to fund at the
basics out of their own money and so I I
don't believe that austerity 2.0 after
the austerity that we've gone through
after the last 12 years it is the right
approach which is why I'm arguing for
two things both fairer choices on taxes
but also crucially a plan for growth
because one of the reasons that we are
in this mess we're in and why we have
been so uniquely exposed in Britain with
one of the lowest growths of any of the
oecd the major industrialized economies
is because we've just been languishing
in the league tables in growth over the
last decade so we need a growth plan
it's why I've set out Labor's green
Prosperity plan because I generally only
believe that Britain can be a global
leader in some of the industries of the
future from Green hydrogen to tidal
energy floating offshore winds carbon
capture and storage creating good jobs
in all parts of Britain helping keep
people's bills low and also boosting our
energy security it's why we're set out
our plans to make Britain the best place
to start and grow a business and
reforming business rates to help our
small businesses and our High Street
Thrive we need all of that because
that's what brings in the money to pay
for our public services and the problem
is now after 12 years of conservative
government growth is on the floor and
inflation is going through the roof I'm
going to jump in just because I've got a
couple more questions that I do want to
squeeze in before I have to let you go
and Jeremy Hunt was saying on a public
sector pay and on strikes if we gave
everyone inflation-proof pay Rises then
inflation would stay at nurses currently
striking they want an above inflation
pay rise of 17 percent do you think
that's affordable
I'm not going to pluck numbers out of
the air but it should be a number that's
on the table for the conservatives
well
it's up to the pay review bodies to work
with the unions but it is a badge of
shame that for the first time in their
history nurses are looking to go on
strike this didn't happen when labor was
in government because we valued and
respected Public Service workers
including those who work in our NHS
who've given so much to our country
these last few years we've got huge
recruitment challenges in the NHS
including amongst nurses at workload
issues issues of stress we've got nurses
that are going to food banks so we need
to support our NHS workers including our
nurses and that means fair but
affordable pay Rises I'm not going to
cut into the uh the pay review
negotiations that are going uh on but
the Secretary of State for health should
meet with the nurses and the nursing
unions and work out a deal and and show
some respect to these crucial Public
Service workers
I've just got one more question to
squeeze in
um over the summer you were pictured uh
chatting at to Rishi sunak at a
Bloomberg a drinks event it was shortly
before he was made prime minister
what were we talking about
uh well we were a reception and uh I
shadowed a richly sooner for about a
year and a half uh we've talked about a
number of things but it also
particularly actually about our children
we both got young children we were
talking about the influence that they
have on our politics
um I was also you know commiserating
with him on on losing the leadership
contest uh he did lose that contest to
Liz truss is now prime minister but he's
not willing to face the people there
should be a general election because he
has no mandates he was not chosen by
either his members and certainly not by
the country there's no mandate for the
cuts and the tax increases that they are
putting through now the people should
have a choice about who their prime
minister and who their Chancellor is
that will only come through a general
election and that's why we desperately
need one to have a mandate for the
decisions that are being made in our
name uh thank you very much indeed
Rachel Reeves the safe space I feel talk
about children in the political Arena
Arena